hoje em dia eu sou futurista e eu
trabalho não só criando futuros
desejáveis mas vendo como concretizá los
o trabalho é com economia criativa e
colaborativa e aí o que eu observo é que
é incrível porque pela primeira vez na
história da humanidade
a gente tem conhecimento a gente tem
recursos ea gente tem pessoas para fazer
absolutamente tudo o que deseja
nunca isso aconteceu na história tem
tudo só não tem a escolha ea decisão e
não tem escolha a decisão porque e hoje
o que eu acho é que a gente não faz
porque a gente não acha que é possível
então não começa
então hoje o que eu pensei fazer é
contar pra vocês porque tem sido
possível sim fazer tudo aquilo que a
gente deseja porque como é que a gente
consegue isso a primeira coisa é mudar o
olhar ou seja mudar a cultura porque a
nossa cultura ela ainda não consegue
enxergar possibilidades a gente só
consegue ver escassez libra quando a
gente achava que o mundo é plano chegou
na beirada caiu no mundo cheio de
monstros
aí a gente mudou o olhar olho pra cima
viu que não era o centro do mundo de 70
começou a navegar viu que o mundo era
redondo e virou redondo pelo menos na
geografia
só que em termos de cultura de
conhecimento de políticas de economia a
gente continua perfeitamente num mundo
plano
porque num mundo plano porque tudo
aquilo que a gente enxerga que a gente
dá valoriza que a gente usa como
referência é só relativa ao mundo o
plano tem a ver com o número com
quantidade com aquilo que é material e o
que é tangível e material é escasso
consome com o uso tem uma maçã se em
pedaços de terras e têm água consumiu
acabou aí o que a gente faz a gente sai
desse óculos de escassez porque
inclusive essa idéia da escassez que
acaba levando também para a ideia da
competição ea gente transforma um óculos
de escassez em óculos que a gente chama
2d porque 2d
por que não olha só mais um mundo plano
tangível
eu olho mais uma dimensão que é a
dimensão do intangível henrique que
acontece no inter viveu intangível é
incrível porque toda cultura
conhecimento criatividade assim como
todas as relações vínculos e ações
coletivas
elas não se esgotam elas se multiplicam
com o uso não consome multiplica
enquanto aqui no terrível no mundo plano
cresce de forma linear um real mas o
real uma massa mais uma maçã carrinhos
um carrinho no inteligível vai
exponencial
é incrível então o que eu preciso
aprender é como é que o ganho essa
exponencial idade
aí tá bom eu tenho agora duas
coordenadas tangível eo intangível um
escasso ou abundante quando as
coordenadas e começa a fazer o que eu
faço uma bússola
aí eu comecei a me achar porque se eu me
acho eu posso escolher melhor decidir
melhor e ter ações mais interessantes
como é que é essa minha bússola aqui no
plano do tangível do material eu tenho o
começo de tudo que é o universo material
tangível a natureza recursos naturais
mas não só a natureza tudo aquilo que
foi feito pelo homem os recursos
tecnológicos
esse espaço lindo todos os recursos
todos os espaços disponíveis
equipamentos instrumentos e etc
então a gente chama aqui na dimensão
ambiental atingível né a gente chama
isso de dimensão ambiental o técnico
natural e aqui na dimensão financeira eu
vou ver todos os tipos de moeda que eu
posso ter moedas sociais todo tipo na
prova e agora tem uma multiplicação de
formas de moedas e de todo tipo de
crédito etc
mas todo mundo que trabalha com arte com
o terceiro setor
sabe que em geral não têm moeda mas a
gente tem a outra face da moeda que é
tempo tempo dedicado às causas
então aqui na minha dimensão financeira
eu não vou mapear só de onde vai vir
moeda eu vou ver também de onde pode vir
tempo
em que pode dedicar tempo aquilo que a
gente está fazendo aí eu vou aqui pro
inteligível incrível tesouro total na
dimensão cultural eu comece o primeiro
com tudo que é simbólico tudo aquilo que
é importante para a gente tudo aquilo
que move e comove todos os símbolos os
valores às crenças as experiências tudo
aquilo que faz parte da minha vida
interior da minha vida e simbólica e
depois eu tenho todas as linguagens
artísticas todo tipo de conhecimento
todo tipo de experiência tudo aquilo que
a criatividade produz essa é a minha
dimensão cultural que a gente chama de
simbólico cultural com ela a partir dela
que a gente faz a gente queria outra
dimensão que é a relativa à sociedade a
dimensão social na dimensão social que
eu vejo eu vejo tudo aquilo que promove
a ação do coletivo onde é que a gente
junta onde é que a gente deixa de ser um
eu para seu o de ser um eles para ser um
nós então primeiro todas as causas
compartilhadas os grupos de
pertencimento o time o partido o que for
depois todas as políticas e os fundos às
instituições a mídia tudo aquilo que faz
com que a gente possa agir de forma
coordenada e integrada muito bom vir
aqui a minha bússola -4 10 que não só
revela uma riqueza imensa porque isso é
que a economia não é aquele pedacinho
ali da moeda
aquele pedacinho ali da moeda inclusive
é muito pouco confiável e borbulha assim
desaparece
a economia é o conjunto de todos esses
patrimônios os patrimônio simbólico
culturais os técnicos tecnológicos e
naturais
o sócio políticos e os financeiros então
isso seria o que a gente chama de
prosperidade 4d que é uma visão de
riqueza muito mais ampla do que sua
moeda
ok então tô entendendo isso aqui e agora
a eu preciso ver como é que esses meus
quatro de se transformam em abundância e
onde está a abundância
a abundância tá no que é exponencial do
que não cresce de forma linear mas no
que cresce em progressão geométrica e é
isso que está acontecendo a gente pensa
que não tem tempo não tem mesmo porque
porque está tudo acontecendo numa
velocidade exponencial
graças às novas tecnologias à rede e ter
todas as possibilidades são
completamente diferentes e qualquer
pessoa que esteja pensando com óculos
que não é nem 2d com óculos do mundo
plano vai se dar muito mal no mundo que
se transforma em velocidade exponencial
observando o processo desde
pequenininhos grupos criativos até muito
grandes quando eu faço políticas
nacionais de desenvolvimento através de
economia criativa eu comecei a observar
que tinha uma espécie de padrão em que
tudo aquilo que dava certo e esse padrão
parecia um pouco com os ciclos da
natureza sabe quando uma coisa ativa a
outra e eu brinco dizendo que eu sou
sintetiza eu não sou analista eu sou
sintetiza quero simplificar juntar
simplificar juntar além de economista
interessa como faz bom então como óculos
dada a abundância eu comecei a ver isso
tudo e comecei a perceber um padrão
esse padrão a gente chama de ciclo
exponencial da abundância é um ciclo
porque um ativo o outro cada um dos
vetores que são os principais vetores de
futuro agora tem uma característica
exponencial e um ativo outro bom por
onde eu começo eu começo pela base que
eu sou sendo que eu pode ser eu mesmo um
profissional pode ser um grupo pode ser
uma cidade pode ser uma empresa pode ser
um país
então eu vou ver o que meu patrimônio
intangível que eu tenho de cultura de
conhecimento onde eu sou o único a onde
está minha diversidade
esse é o meu maior tesouro este tesouro
é a base da economia criativa que é uma
economia que gera riqueza e qualidade de
vida a partir desses ativos intangíveis
dar um exemplo simples pensa no ipad
dos 500 dólares do ipad 23 vão pra
tangíveis e os outros vão para
inteligíveis design marca a comunicação
etc
bom então tá bom eu sei que eu tenho de
único que eu tenho quais são meus
patrimônios intangíveis
só que tudo isso aqui sempre existiu
sempre teve linguagens artísticas
conhecimento criatividade porque agora
isto é a base do futuro da sociedade e
economia no futuro e da possibilidade
real de sustentabilidade
aqui na dimensão ambiental a chave
porque eu tenho as novas tecnologias e
com elas eu consigo fazer com que esse
meu tesouro seja visível acessível e tem
um processo pensão uma mina de ouro de
petróleo
senão ela não tem valor se não está
visível acessível e tem um processo
as novas tecnologias de informação e
comunicação fazem isso tornam visível e
acessível esse meu tesouro aqui dos
intangíveis e aí olha que mais dá pra
fazer
vou dar um exemplo não sei se vocês
conhecem uma hora hotel do mundo
chama-se hebe e ele mapeia aí cria
processos para que todo mundo que queira
alugar uma casa um espaço de seta possa
fazer 10 milhões de leite até 2012 uma
hora hotel do mundo não gastou uma grama
de cimento não tem nenhum funcionário
não gastou um centavo de comunicação e
por quê porque ele usou as novas
tecnologias para mapear todos os tudo
aquilo que estava disponível e podia ser
usado de outra maneira
ele mapeou os hardwares disponíveis as
estruturas e criou um outro processo
para isso é o que a gente pode fazer com
a dimensão ambiental
a gente vê pergunta que já tem aqui que
eu posso usar melhor porque sempre tem
pra caramba um monte de espaço um monte
de equipamento um monte de material só
não está visível ea gente precisa criar
o processo para poder conectar isso tudo
aí para em terríveis infinitos
se multiplicam exponencialmente ativados
pelas novas tecnologias
um mundo real infinitos mundos virtuais
nas novas tecnologias também entre você
e eu só um caminho mas através das redes
infinitos caminhos aí combinamos essas
duas coisas deu o que processos
colaborativos em rede
aí é incrível nisso não estamos no
começo é pré história aqui dessa parte
que é na dimensão social
mas aí a gente consegue fazer qualquer
coisa
se a gente junta tempo conhecimento às
novas tecnologias ea vontade de
colaborar das pessoas
exemplo clássico oab que pede a ser
impossível qualquer país ou empresa
fazia wikipedia
aí a gente olha falando existe tudo
muito bonito
só que colabora como se a gente tá assim
com a corda no pescoço ninguém tem tempo
nem têm dinheiro ninguém tem recurso
será mesmo primeiro porque colaborando é
a única maneira que a gente tem de
ganhar tempo recurso etc e depois se a
gente for ver sabe quanto tempo demorou
a fazer o wikipedia é 100 milhões de
horas a gente fala meu deus religiosa
muito tempo não tem não tem sabe quanto
a gente vê de tv por ano no mundo 1
trilhão de horas na frente da tv
dava pra fazer 10 mil e pedras um jogo
de copa do mundo dava para fazer 3 e 6 e
pedras se lerá se o tempo das pessoas
assim dava o equivalente a 41 mil anos
para um jogo da copa do mundo sendo
assistidos no brasil tempo tempo o que
não tem a escolha como nós falamos no
começo então quando a gente passa a ser
nós tudo é possível
lembra que um exponencial lisa um
elevado a 500 quilômetros é só um
aí a gente olha e fala nossa vai ser
incrível seremos felizes
a gente tem infinito aqui exponencial
conhecimento infinito aqui exponencial
novas tecnologias infinito aqui
exponencial processo de colaboração
lindo só tem um pequeno problema lhe na
dimensão financeira tudo isso está
rigorosamente
invisível porque porque a nossa cultura
é do mundo plano
a gente só tem métricas de medir o que é
numérico quantitativo financeiro pib pib
mede consumo é uma coisa completamente
absurda
então a questão toda é que pode permitir
que isso aqui realmente cria um outro
mundo é a gente mudar as nossas métricas
e é isso que a gente tem feito a gente
chama isso de matriz 4d e é mapear todos
os recursos que a gente tem culturais
ambientais sociais e financeiros ver
como é que a gente circula isso tudo e
mais ainda como é que dá pra ter
resultado nas quatro deles porque não
importa a gente gerar moeda
quem disse que a moeda vai ser a solução
para a vida está cada vez mais claro que
não então a gente quer recursos 4d
eu quero gerar mais conhecimento
criatividade e valores humanos eu quero
gerar o melhor uso de todos os meus
recursos tecnológicos gerais
eu quero gerar mais ação conjunta mais
participação política mais sensação de
nós mas fazer coletivo e eu quero ter
uma economia uma prosperidade 4d
circulando recursos de toda natureza
então ok
temos 14 de temos aqui o ciclo
exponencial da abundância e agora vamos
ver como é que funciona na prática o
processo na prática chama criando
comunidades criativas e colaborativas e
por que tantos e porque 26 juntos aqui
bonitinho 26 juntos fazem com que a
essência de tudo o que a gente viu agora
a pouco o coração então se não é com o
coração se não é com afeto se não é com
desejo com alegria coisa não funciona e
qual é o coração desse processo todo pra
gente ali no meio aquilo que é capaz de
fazer com que a escassez se transforme
em abundância é a criação de futuros
desejáveis
a gente vai ver que a gente quer é claro
porque eu vou fazer algo que eu não
quero eu quero saber que eu quero eu vou
trabalhar pra isso e aí que é legal
quando eu criei futuros desejáveis
eu olho e fala nessa não é que aquele
ali também é a mesma coisa que eu ia
ele também a então não é que a gente é a
humanidade ea gente quer todo mundo é a
mesma coisa então a gente parta junto
sem medo
e aí legal tema lhe atraindo a gente o
futuro desejável mas a única coisa real
que existe é o agora então eu tenho que
trazer o futuro desejável pro agora e
dizer beleza
queremos aquilo ali hoje com quem somos
e o que temos
o que é que dá pra fazer essa é a
pergunta então vamos ver que a gente
pode fazer e aí a gente começa num ciclo
então a primeira coisa que eu tenho que
fazer eu tenho que conhecer o primeiro
do ces
eu tenho que conhecer os meus
patrimônios intangíveis tudo aquilo que
eu sou
ou seja eu pessoa a cidade e país
empresa
não adianta só conhecer os meus
intangíveis as coisas só têm valor e só
podem gerar alguma coisa se elas estão
comunicados
então os meus primeiros 26 aqui dá a
dimensão inteligível são conhecer e o
comunicar com isso eu posso ir pra lá e
eu já sei meu softwares agora precisa
dos favores
então eu vou ver que eu tenho pra que eu
tenho que eu posso conectar pra fazer
alguma coisa com isso que recursos que
espaços que equipamentos que matérias
primas etc e vou conectar todas essas
possibilidades
por exemplo será que a gente precisa
criar mais espaços o que a gente precisa
otimizar aquilo que já tá agora conectar
legal mas conectar pra que essa é a
pergunta chave pra que eu vou conectar
para o bem comum
isso é o futuro a gente consegue coisas
exponenciais quando a gente está
trabalhando para o bem comum
já para trabalhar para o mercado não
exponencial lisa vai linear
a gente continua trabalhando na coluna
competição e não na colaboração mas se
eu estou trabalhando para o bem comum
para cuidar
aí fala e aí como eu tenho isso aqui
quando eu chego aqui na dimensão social
as pessoas colaboram meus e é
colaborar agora às vezes é difícil
começar um processo de colaboração a
gente consegue quando a gente tem causas
isso é o principal elemento ativador
mans é meio complicado de manter aí a
gente vai olhar quem dá certo e eu morro
de inveja de quem dá certo como o
futebol por exemplo por que é que tu
ninguém se mobiliza para essa causa um
pouco importante de mudar o mundo mas se
mobiliza para caramba e é feriado
nacional e para tudo por causa do
futebol
bom que o futebol tem um futebol
divertido futebol me dá prazer me dá
alegria no futebol no carnaval tudo
aquilo que é justo eu celebro então
outros e que permite a continuidade da
colaboração é a celebração tem que ser
bonito gostoso alegre divertido
ninguém se junta para lutar pelo amor de
deus isso aqui ó escassez mundo plano já
era a gente se junta para celebrar e pra
fazer junto e aí beleza tá tudo lindo
como é que eu vou viabilizar isso a
minha prosperidade 4d e ali pra eu poder
circular todos os recursos 4 de que
existem e é incrível como existem quando
a gente faz isso em geral num grupo de
20 pessoas já tem aqui dentro os
recursos para viabilizar os futuros
desejáveis que eram o coraçãozinho bom
mas para poder usar eles têm que estar
acreditados que é acreditado eu tenho
que saber o que tem e precisa ter
alistado de uma forma tal que depois de
acreditar de saber o que é que eu tenho
eu possa cumprir o objetivo da dimensão
financeira que circular porque ele vai
circulando e ativando então temos aqui
ao criando comunidades criativas e
colaborativas
eu tenho então conhecer comunicar
conectar cuidar a colaborar celebrar e
acreditar circular tudo certo
fácil né e por que não é porque é que
não é tudo aí é simples dá
garanto para vocês da funci ona é
simples porque não dá porque com meu
óculos aquele da escassez e alimentado
pela maior indústria do mundo que a
indústria do medo falta o coração daqui
que é o que confiar não funciona porque
porque não confia a gente acha que não
dá não faz agora será que eu tenho um
motivo pra confiar eu poderia por
exemplo confiasse eu achasse que não
somos uma unidade que a gente é uma
coisa só
será vamos pensar um pouco que foi a
história da humanidade desde o começo
que a gente fez foi criar símbolos
conhecimento criatividade percepção e
criar maneiras de conectar e circular
isso seja através de pinturas nas
cavernas ou através da internet e da web
ea gente tem feito isso desde o início a
gente cria símbolos percepção ea gente
queria maneiras de compartilhar a
incluir essa percepção
agora penso o seguinte se a hipótese de
gaia de que a terra é um ser vivo é fato
a última coisa que se forma nos seres
vivos é o sistema nervoso e que faz o
sistema nervoso ele faz exatamente isso
ele percebe ele queria e ele queria
fluxos para que a gente possa agir
então eu acho que nós somos o sistema
nervoso de gaia a informação cada um de
nós um neurônio
vocês podem me ajudar aqui um pouquinho
vocês 4 que eu preciso pra poder ser um
bom sistema nervoso de gaia
eu preciso me conectar eu não posso
dizer não eu não sinapses chega aqui
perto para sinalizar comigo eu não
assinasse com ele porque ele é de outro
time outro partido sobre ele com ele ele
com ele tal a gente tem que se adaptar
a gente tem que conectar agora adianta
conectar só nós estamos conectados pra
caramba no celular resolveu está
faltando uma parte
e que no celular não tem e eu tenho que
conectar e me afetar que é afetar eu me
transformo eu te percebo eu me
transformo é assim que tem até corrente
elétrica o elétron se transforma ele
veio de um jeito de nené conector feito
algo mudou há correntes que aconteceu
então eu tenho que me afetar
agora que acontece quando eu me afeta
eu sinto que eu sinto eu não sei o que
fazer com isso porque eu vou fazer com
que eu sentia
e além do mais eu senti eu fiquei
vulnerável e se eu tô vulnerável que vai
acontecer
eu não posso ficar vulnerável porque
para chegar vai chegar mais perto aqui
que nós estamos com medo né que nós
temos é que eu vou fazer
vulnerável sentindo querendo fazer vendo
que está tudo aí que não dá pra fazer
a questão toda é a gente perceber que dá
sim para estar vulnerável
dá sim para acreditar dá sim pra confiar
e dá sim pra junto se jogar no futuro
possível porque as pessoas são incríveis